هي اجهزه راح تكون شغاله 24 ساعه لو طفت
توفيت كل اختصار
[موسيقى]
بهذه الكلمات يستذكر الشاب السعودي
ابراهيم القاسم البالغ من العمر 34 عاما
معاناته السابقه مع مرض فشل القلب الذي تم
تشخيصه عام 2018 بعد الام مفاجئه شعر بها
واعاقت نشاطه قرر على اثرها اطباء مستشفى
الملك فيصل التخصصي في الرياض زراعه قلب
له من متبرع بعد البحث اتضح لي انه العلاج
راح يكون ان شاء الله في مستشفى الملك
فيصل التخصصي
فرفعنا لهم طلب وجت الموافقه
واذكر انه دخلوني اللي هو في العنايه
بعدين طلعوني فتره كذا بسيطه بحيث انه
يعني يشوفون وش الدراسات تطلع معاهم
اتضح انه راح يكون في عمليه زراعه زراعه
قلبي القلب عندي صار شبه فاشل او يعني
منتهي الا الا شيء بسيط
437 عمليه زراعه قلوب اجرتها وحده زراعه
القلب في مستشفى الملك فيصل التخصصي منها
67 عمليه لاطفال دون الرابعه عشره من
العمر عاده في الناس اللي بيكونوا في سن
صغيره او في في مقتبل العمر الجاهل الملخص
الصناعيه الا كجسر للزراعه لكن في الناس
اللي لا تنطبق عليهم
الزراعه او في سن متقدمه نلجا الى المضخات
الصناعيه ويرجع لها كحل يعني دائم مثل
حاله المريض ابراهيم زرعنا له مضخ في
الايمن والايسر وهذه اليسرى كانت تسحب من
البطين الايسر الدم وتضخه في الاورطه اللي
هو الشريان الكبير اللي يوزع الدم على
بقيه الجسم والبطينه الايمن زرع فيه كمان
مضخه اخرى مثل في يدي دائمه تقوم باخذ
الدم اللي موجود في البطينه الايمن اللي
غير مؤكسد وارساله الى الشريان الرئوي
علشان يتاكسد ثلاثه اعوام عاشها ابراهيم
على المضخات الصناعيه التي توقفت فجاه عن
العمل في اكتوبر الماضي فاضطر الاطباء
لاتخاذ اجراء سريع وفي غضون ساعات معدوده
تم استبدال قلبه بقلب متبرع متوفى دماغيا
وبدعم عائلته وفريق الاطباء اصبح يعيش
حياه طبيعيه
الحين الحمد لله ما في ولا سلك بس في
علاجات العلاجات هذه هي اللي تخليك يعني
بعد الله هي اللي تخلي الجسم طبيعي كامل
بدون علاجات
يعني فيها معوقات كثيره
تكلفه مليونيه لعمليه زراعه القلب الواحده
الى انها تنفذ بشكل مجاني في المركز
الوحيد بالسعوديه والخليج الذي احيا الامل
في قلوب عشرات المرضى منذ اربعه اعوام
غاد الفهد العربيه الرياض
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات